[Music]
okay so the next section is 7 to 12 from
low defense into this section it's all
attacks and counter-attacks it's quite
interesting to look at the Carter that's
why I'll be out the character and the KU
v jo and to Ken how many attacking moves
there are because there's a lot more
technique moves or defensive moves
so if you see likely that was really
defensive and reactive this all may be
suggested it's not that way all the time
okay hey leap from 4 to 7 so blah fan
now he Robin striking magellan way he
just doesn't know defense this is the
start position for 7 to 12 you start
from this position which is 6 so next
moves gonna be 7 side turn strike strike
again let's try forward these steps so
huh growl he begins to raise whiny
tonight the old one Hey or you can go to
the roof
person pregnancies always may be over in
Korea most obvious one each be back
moved four speeds of tape through here
like where I paint curls somewhat not
always going to be on the top nine ten
so I'm aiming straight these elbows and
this succeed these are now going to
strike to the lower edge slips that
drops the floor for weapons twelve
nights saying these often a tricky
combination and what ten snap these when
further gets to nine here he's up ready
right if you wait for this to come down
you can't eat beginning you get the
strike in so it is you can get it solved
crushed move doesn't really work you're
working in a long distance doesn't films
weird pretty much something that we do I
guess often number 9 goes backwards he
goes backwards in the Carter and I think
it was I think it was introducing going
backwards when when people were teaching
in very large groups safety if you're in
a smaller group that's not really an
issue obviously you'll be you know okay
I pull the Train sensibly but making you
go back boys you end up so far away
doesn't make much sense
number ten is really padding strike and
you should be able to deliver that quite
easy to us how we go
so from here you should be able to your
back way see it's just twisting to move
thing together teleport much into like
that's pretty yeah pretty bad
I like to easy hit things good tests
your best power and get there's no big
city on the move right we should be a
get into any of these moves from posture
posture posture every time you move
moving with power and structure it's
kind of the point of the QB Joe you my
dear okay so eight twelve
[Music]
you